[Music]
in a place like MIT you have people from
all over the world from very different
backgrounds ethnicities and races and
cultures and the ome is a place where
you can find people that probably have
your same background in my case there's
one of those Tov members those Puerto
Ricans so that's always nice for me to
go in and just talk to her there open
arms no matter who you are where you're
from at the core of this mission to make
the world a better place
is empowering students with that mindset
with that mind at hand mind setting
giving them the tools that they need in
order to be effective in that mission
and the army plays a distinctive role in
that and making sure that these students
are successful for many students they
find within the OMA that this is the
community that becomes for their home we
have a portfolio of about 25 different
programs that really do help students
navigate MIT but also think about what
they want to do beyond MIT the ome has a
number of corporate sponsors and
supporters that come in and talk to
students about resume writing dressing
for success and sort of being able to
navigate the job and internship
opportunities I'm grace tan long
nasa/jpl
I am on the university programs team
here at Google Cambridge I think that's
really valuable I think it's special
that those companies come specifically
for they only in to like see
underrepresented minorities success and
successes the Army has given it to me is
all about confidence and feeling like
you understand your environment
you